it is 7 35.
five minutes behind
um
Blueberry Morning got some snow
yesterday I'm gonna ride some lines
do some flips
it's gonna be a good day
I was up in Alaska with my crew working
on this film the fourth phase
let's do this wizard thing real quick it
looks extremely good
you need a canvas to put your work on
and the type of art that I like to make
demands a very large canvas and that is
Alaska
you find snow features in Alaska that
you don't find anywhere else in the
world
my first couple trips I was really
scared and scared not just on a I might
get hurt but like there was a death
component you have cornice is on The
Ridges you have crevasses
there's a lot of big Cliffs
you get out of a helicopter on top of a
ridge
and you look a couple thousand feet down
and there's an absolute moment of leap
of faith
and then drop in and surrender to the
unknown
everything in your body is like speed
check speed check you're going too fast
slow down
and you can
you have to just try to override the
body's natural ability to protect itself
Avalanches of course are a constant
thing that you're thinking and talking
about
I've been skiing in the big mouth for
over 25 years and I've seen a lot of bad
things go down
if you get caught in an avalanche on a
big Alaskan face
you're not stopping until the bottom
just do a little snow check here
okay
with all these dangers why put yourself
out there
for me riding in Alaska it's the art
that I have worked towards for so many
years and all of the little subtleties
and the nuances and the details like
that's where it matters
[Music]